саакашвілі депортиво ла і проти нього
партію за наймом c хоче продуманий суворо
ти активісти руку нових посилання своїм
новачкам флешмобом били адміністрації
президента вся акція справа видно
висловлюєш неправильно кашміру марші за
імпічмент порошенка не було вже маже
два місяці я думаю думаєш люди опустили
руки і наречений чи то пак і протестували
буду вони цінні так мало бала від нас 4
корінних його раді руку нових сил вона
цілком заявляєш ч після депортації
саакашвілі
масового виток з партії дісталося а у
тим лід сутність лідера хочу увійти
ви знаєте ольга зрештою психологічно woman
шубу Михайла не був їм всіх щоб hal
вперед і всі ми обидва їх таки круглі
і кида напролом і досі amazon їм за
раз в озвучкою названий вище трах рух
нових сил активно готуватися до
парламентських виборів 2019 партія
гаїті
руйнує ідеальність в регіонах нині
я маже туристів сердю здається псуєте
наше завдання за 1 с сформувати та
5 мільйонів вибір цифр юшку нових сил
через особисті контакти на 200 тисяч
ідейних і справи річкових партійців в руку на
маца
партії хизб одягаєтеся чіп ранку загиблого
владу ван із мужик повернуто і саакашвілі
в Україну причому на посаду
прем'єр-міністра
у темно для заданих і різьблених суті
логічних досвід іван рух нових сил моя
максимум один вид соток дувер та
населення oodji
покажи відпочинок шанси проти парламенту
найму без об'єктів з тут уже шую
політичну силу
поважають у просторі німецького фонду
імені фрідріха еберта директора
представлений are so very thick будинок
бітних плані в партії саакашвілі
ставиться дуже скептично
від жвавої нори замовила хитатися партію на
втрати та кібер 6 змаже 300 40 азара
суворих політичних сил в Україні
такі знімають вони продуману програмою
вони стратегії вони тим більше рожеві
цієї структури аджи тварі волосся біля краю
маму політика пряма нога у дивишся
тільки почали партійця харизматично fuse
пригостися сем уже ти добра а лощину
харизматичний лідер знаку я йогу
наверное wing star
я популярність сиплеться вся партія вся
структура
розум з ним так і часто трапляється вам
білизна для партії США далеко вигляд хаска
поважайте і клініки
оля гола баладам він будує дойче велле
статус такої популярності історії ніг
партій та карина кіль
у соціальних міражах з 3g що пісня
депортація саакашвілі проходили kill
стануть ще більше зараза та підрахуй
кінець може автора мільйона людей
проти реального світла на вулицях Києва
у потенціал руку нових сил вірити хоч
носить парк авантюра вимагати заміни вони
атаки але послав нехай їх
організувати
добре але сказав нічого не
рух нових сил збирається в одній цій
свої регулярні морщі центром криво та
народні збори на вихідних париж та
після двомісячної парирувати флешмоб
заряд ставку порошенка та 2 дано ще на
ібіце
дві сотні пар або kill счп 2 місяці
цьому акції протесту розпочалися саакашвілі
з брала кіка тисяч людей на вулицях Києва